I've heard of a lettuce Clerk chances
are you haven't but it's exactly what it
sounds like
basically it's a mean where you get a
bunch of kids together with heads of
lettuce and you got five minutes to eat
the whole thing it seems to have started
it at the main school for science and
mathematics and then it went viral on
tumblr after a user called at least six
dragons shared a photo of the whole
weird thing we actually tracked down one
of the original members of the main
school for science and mathematics
lettuce Club whose name is Luke Peterson
and they gave BuzzFeed some really
interesting tips about how to consume as
much lettuce as possible lettuce is
mainly water so you can take gigantic
bites of that stuff and it won't fill up
your mouth that much if you chew quickly
you can take you know big big bites you
can tear it up and you can stop it in
your mouth bigger the bite the faster
you get it down as long as you're
willing to chew quickly in the spirit of
journalism we decided that we would also
hold the first-ever BuzzFeed
like I'm gonna just have this massive
heart attack